estelle bonjour quel faut-il retenir de
ces annonces du président français eh
bien c'était une allocation à devinettes
dizaines de 1 minute le chef de l'état a
tout d'abord évoqué le combat mené par
le pays contre le virus c'est le défi
auquel il doit faire face un pur
notamment équiper correctement les
soignants il a rappelé les décisions
prises pour subvenir à ses besoins en
matériel médical et le tourner notamment
les commandes de masques passé à la
chine le chef de l'état qui a salué le
travail la mobilisation et le
savoir-faire des industriels français
pour produire les masques dont le pays a
besoin d'ici trois à quatre semaines
nous aurons la possibilité de produire
un million de masques par jour a assuré
emmanuel macron je vous rappelle que les
personnels hospitaliers ont besoin de 40
millions de masques par semaine le chef
de l'état qui a aussi indiqué qu'un
consortium d'industriels allait
construire dix mille un respirateur du
site
elle animait et puis un autre à lyon
c'est bien c'est cette dotation à 2,4
milliards d'euros elles sont et public
france pour assurer la production du
matériel sanitaire nécessaire pour faire
face à l épidémie et puis dans un second
temps emmanuel macron a rappelé l
importance capitale de produire
davantage sur le sol français
il souhaite une indépendance pleine et
entière du pays d'ici la fin de l'année
dans la production de masques pour lui
c'est une priorité je vous propose
d'écouter la croix le monde a changé
depuis quelques semaines a créé une
tension inédite sur les marchés mondiaux
et des difficultés profondes
le gouvernement a édicté une doctrine
pour ne jamais être en rupture et
pouvoir toujours équipé les soignants
qui sont les plus exposés au virus
les déstockages se font chaque semaine
et nous continuons d'être vigilant mais
pour faire face à la crise à ces 40
millions de masques dont nous avons
besoin par semaine au moins
plusieurs décisions ont été prises
d'abord celle d'importer massivement et
vite
plus d'un milliard de masques venant de
chine et les commandes sont en train
d'arriver avec des commandes
supplémentaires qui sont d'ores et déjà
passé mais il nous faut aussi est à mes
yeux aujourd'hui avant toute chose
produire davantage en france sur notre
sol produire parce que cette crise nous
enseigne que sur certains biens certains
produits certains matériaux le caractère
stratégique impose d'avoir une
souveraineté européenne
produire plus sur le sol national pour
réduire notre dépendance et donc nous
équiper dans la durée cette intervention
la vue le chef de l'état s'est entretenu
avec des salariés des responsables de
visite de masques kolmi hopen à
l'initiative de l'un des salariés tous
ensemble applaudi les français qui sont
sur le front
pendant cette crise que traverse le pays
je vous rappelle que cette usine kolmi
hopen que le chef de l'état a visité
donc est le plus gros producteur de
masques sur le territoire
l'usiné tourne dorénavant 24 heures sur
24 merci est el farj pour ces précisions